at what point when you were at drake
university did you know you were going
to come to la
oh yeah um so that's a good question
um i think i was thinking about dropping
out
in freshman year because like i i
sort of you know i kind of got that bug
about like well maybe maybe this is not
the right place for me and i had
this advisor uh todd evans who was great
and he convinced me like just stay in it
you know just just keep doing it like
you'll learn a lot here it may not be a
film school
but in this program you'll really learn
a lot and so i i did i stuck
into it and i'm happy that i did um
because it really allowed me when
um i was in my senior year to go ahead
and take the chance to like
get an internship in los angeles and my
dad knew somebody knew
somebody who lived out here and had
access to the uta
job list i have no idea if that's still
a thing but it was full of like
jobs and uh internships and everything
and so i just started submitting
internships like mad
like get me out there for a summer i
need a summer internship
i need to know if los angeles is right
for me
you know because there were a couple
other places that were filmmaker
friendly i think austin was a place that
i was thinking about
doing it in minnesota wasn't a thing
like back in the day
yeah there were there wasn't really a
lot of people doing film in minnesota i
think that has changed um because i've
met a lot of people out of here out here
that are from minnesota and so it seems
like filmmaking is sort of catching on
which is fantastic
but it was it was getting an internship
and landing that
um you know in that summer the summer of
2006 it was
that i was able to come out and uh you
know it was a terrifying thing to do
you know for me going from minnesota you
know like
generally a smaller town i didn't live
in the twin cities i lived you know
in a suburb like 20 minutes north and uh
you know like you you come to la
and you're on the 10. and and i remember
going like where's the hollywood sign
and i was looking to my right because i
saw the mountains i was like where's the
hollywood sign
and in classic this is what happens when
you first come to la story
i look forward and traffic had stopped
and i rear-ended somebody
oh my goodness yeah and it wasn't a bad
rear ending it was just a bump
but that was my introduction to la is
getting into traffic on the 10 and rear
ending somebody
which everybody should have and i'm sure
so many people do
but um but yeah after that you know and
sort of getting my bearings
in la um i very quickly found over the
summer that like
the town was for me you know like
it it fit my vibe it was full of people
who were like
me you know who were passionate about
film passion about entertainment
you know interesting creative artsy
hard workers you know and so diverse
and that's that's the one thing that i
learned about like being on set
is that like you meet so many different
people from so many walks of life you
know
from like the craftsman you know in the
art department to the grips
you know to the camera people like those
are all very different people
you know different types of people want
to be grips
versus want to be camera nerds versus
you know or set decorators or costumers
or
you know the ads like it's it's a lot of
different people but it's
great and how all of those disparate
personalities sort of come together
and like make something that can be
transcendent
like that is is kind of the beauty of
making films
so it's 2006 you're driving around
you're you're feeling good
you know wind in your hair and then the
recession hits
yeah and what happens then yeah so
um i had been doing pa work
um you know going from various project
to various projects big projects to
small projects an unpaid project to
semi-paid projects and stuff like that
and i remember it was around the
recession and the writers strike
and i had just done a stint as a
director's assistant on indie feature
which was super fun and i learned a lot
um and i was doing reality tv
which i never thought that i would do
but like somebody offered me a gig and
when you need a gig you take a gig
so i was a driver um for one of these
reality shows shot over in west
hollywood you know driving people from
parking up into the mansion in the hills
oh that's great um so it was it was a
trip
um but i i realized like it was around
christmas time
i was sitting in this van pretty much
all day i was getting fat
you know and i was i the biggest thing
is that i
wasn't able to
[Music]
to write or even direct that was i mean
directing was like
i can't afford that you know what i mean
like so i had to at least write but i
couldn't even do that
because you know you're working five or
six days a week sometimes even seven
and it's at least 12 hours you're
definitely working
you know 14 sometimes 16 you know it's
long and you just come home exhausted
and i found that it sapped any sort of
creative
drive that i had in me and i hated that
because i was here to make stuff
i wasn't making stuff so i had to
you know really think about it and go
do i want to keep doing this you know
i'm sitting
at the top of this parking structure in
west hollywood in this passenger van
getting fat being unhappy like
i need something that's going to help me
get
to that goal of writing directing full
time
was an office job that's what i figured
out it's like you know what i need the
structure
i need the five-day work week i need
nine to five
nine to six but i need nights i need
weekends
so that i can do what i want to do and i
was able to find that i reconnected
with a buddy that i met at the
internship
and uh he was like hey just so happens
that
there's a receptionist spot open like do
you want that
i was like you know what yeah you know i
was
man maybe 25 at the time you know like
two or three years doing pa stuff and it
was it
mentally it was like okay this is
definitely starting over it's starting
at the bottom
it's a receptionist you know there's no
there's no
uh you know guarantee that it'll lead to
anything but i was like you know what
like
i will do it and that's one of those
risks that i was like i have to take
you know i have to take that risk i will
start from the bottom uh again if i need
to
in order to make it that i can
shoot and and write and and have that
time so
i took the plunge um and it worked out
and for me
getting an office job was what i needed
to get my creative flow going
and and to keep it going which is
interesting because you would think
doing the same thing or having you know
that set schedule
every day like wouldn't that make you
you know not
as creative or you know if life was
monotonous you know
would it uh but i found that uh that i
needed that and helped me you know when
i came home like
i could write and like you know i was
much more creative
i find that so interesting that at 25
you knew you needed structure
that's really that's really interesting
to me yeah
but before you thought it was going to
be more of this like free-for-all
cool i'm going to be making movies and
then you realize oh wait a minute i need
some type of discipline
in order to be freer and creative
yeah that's really interesting i mean
because the thing that i found
was that when you're constantly looking
for work and trying to survive
that's where your brain power goes you
know you need to find that next job
you need to pay rent you need to eat
that doesn't really leave a lot of time
for like what's this amazing short film
concept or what's this feature i could
do you know
so it's a lot of hustling and for me it
was
hard to fit in you know a lot of the
creative stuff
when i was sort of struggling to survive
so it really was a
let me just get an office job that will
pay me and i don't have to worry about
that then
and that way more brain power is freed
up
so then i can concentrate on you know
what creative ideas do i have how do i
make this
fascinating so since then how many films
have you made shorts or features
included yeah yeah um i've written a lot
more
than i've shot because shooting in la is
expensive
that's just the fact of life because you
want to pay people
you know crew members a decent wage
like i feel like terrible and i couldn't
make people like
work for nothing you know i mean that's
that's after working for nothing it's
really hard for me to go like hey
please work for nothing because i know i
know what that's like
um so it's very expensive to shoot stuff
so i haven't shot
a ton of things but i have written an
enormous amount of things
um and that was all in the service of
getting those
10 000 hours in so you know it was
it was breaking you know stories with my
writing partner will about this
like sci-fi web series and we did that
for a while
and that helped us figure out like how
to make worlds
you know because everything started to
turn to
a more like franchise model and a world
building model in terms of hollywood
um so that was very helpful for us you
know and it's learnings that we've
used when we've gone to create you know
tv shows
um it's like how do you create a world
and how do you do that
um so yeah yeah i've
written a bunch written a bunch of
features um
yeah you crowdfunded over 30 grand yes
pretty amazing
so you know there was stuff that we shot
for low budget but you know when we got
the opportunity to work with heidi
moneymaker and zoe bell
on this short film project called no
touching which is an action
horror piece about two girls who get
into this haunted house where the people
running it are
misogynistic and start grabbing and
touching them inappropriately
you don't do that to zooey bell or heidi
moneymaker because they're gonna kick
your ass
and that is that is what happens in no
touching they they kick ass all
throughout this haunted house
so it's very fun but for that i mean we
knew
that it had to be done right you know so
we didn't have access to 30 grand so we
had to
resort to kickstarter which was great
you